au coeur du morvan à château-chinon
ville dont françois mitterrand a été le
maire pendant 22 ans il est un lieu que
les touristes ne manqueraient pour rien
au monde un petit hôtel 3 étoiles le
vieux morvan
c'est ici que le 10 mai 1981 françois
mitterrand a fêté sa victoire sur le
balcon de l'hôtel du vieux morvan pour
remercier les électeurs du village et
les lettres
françois mitterrand premier président
socialiste de la vème république était
un homme énigmatique
nous avons demandé à ceux qui l'ont
côtoyé de près pendant deux septennats à
l'elysée de brosser son portrait avec
pierre tourlier chauffeur et garde du
corps
nous allons revenir sous les ors et les
dorures des l'elysée j'étais de la
petite souris que 68 longue français
voulait d'être au volant de sa r30 de
l'époque il a partagé bien des secrets
avec le président c'était le lieu où
françois mitterrand parlait le plus s'il
était sûr pas est écoutée d'été sur de
jeunes eux ce ne soit pas répéter nous
verrons comment christian prouteau
chargé de la sécurité à protéger la
fille cachée de françois mitterrand
mazarine comme genre et ceux qui étaient
au courant ne savait pas qui était au
courant donc personne n'en parlait
enfin nous rencontrerons diego goldberg
photographes accrédités et pascal
rostain paparazzi qui pendant des années
ont cherché à cerner la personnalité du
président on n'avait pas de rapports
avec françois mitterrand event distance
il y avait une froideur n'était pas
expansif
avec ces sentiments ou avec pour montrer
ses sentiments à la limite je crois
qu'il était timide en plus je n'aime pas
la confidence hébergea apercevrez petite
histoire et grands secrets de la garde
rapprochée de françois mitterrand
[Musique]
diego goldberg et l'argentin qui connaît
certainement le mieux château chinon en
parmi des centaines de photographes il
est le seul à pouvoir suivre françois
mitterrand presque partout et quasiment
tout le temps discret réservé au fil de
ces clichés
diego tisse une relation de confiance
avec françois mitterrand
en fait j'ai chargé très peu de mots
avec lui très peu de monde par exemple
il ya des moments où je sais pas on
était à table de jeunes et à la che ou
des 10 des déchets n'est privé avec des
amis ou la famille il voyait que je fais
c'est pas de photo il était surpris il
m'est cher ges comme disait alors
pourquoi tu es si je mens rien c'est
pour ça que j'avais dit relancer très
peu de jeux chat la souris j'avais
l'image de lui toujours seul et je crois
que beaucoup de nos photos le exprime sa
j'avais l'impression que sa stratégie sa
tactique
tout se passait dans sa tête lors de la
campagne présidentielle de 1981 ou plus
près de françois mitterrand diego le
photographe et pierre le chauffeur
deviennent inséparables
deux vieux complices qui ne se sont pas
revus depuis 30 ans changé d'un poil
toujours pareil moi ça va changer ça
s'ils ont tous fait c'est quand même
émouvant de là pour moi en tout cas
eh bien nous sommes donc dimanche 10 mai
1981 le deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle ce 10 mai 1981 à 20
heures précises au vieux morvan pierre
tournier et diego goldberg
vive les résultats aux côtés du tout
nouveau président de la république
ils vont vivre une soirée inoubliable on
arrivait à la mairie mme bossé beaucoup
de monde
peu après 10 heures du soir à la mairie
de château chinon
j'étais derrière monde me voit à la télé
ah oui alma photo cd nuit de dos tous
les clans du départ ce soir là quand
pierre prend le volant
il pleut des cordes le nouveau président
a bien failli ne jamais pouvoir
rejoindre la capitale
d'écraser personnes qui me disait t'es
pas comme il pleuvait et à être
tellement de monde dans cette petite
courbe devant la mairie que les gens
s'agglutinent s accrocher à la voiture
est un jeu pas il n'a pas fait exprès il
a des suites glace fonctionner d'un seul
coup il a retenu les suit glacée puis il
essuie glace s'est arrêté derrière
j'avais une voiture de sécurité et ça
tombait bien donc on a repris la r30
pour rentrer et dans la voiture il y a
beaucoup d'ambiance entre château chinon
et et paris parle beaucoup entre avec
daniel et il chante l'internationale sa
première fois que j'entendais chanter
arrivé au au péage d'un seul coup on
voit les motards ils veulent nous faire
passer à un péage sans payer et non non
non on commence pas comme ça on va payer
ils ont bloqué toute manière on pourra
pas payer s'est ouverte mais faut pas
que ça continue un et puis parce qu'il
dit mais on va voir tous ces moteurs
tout le temps il vous avez voulu être
élu c'est la charge maintenant c'est
émouvant d'être élu président de la
république et c soit émouvant
s'apercevoir qu'on l'est
[Musique]
dix jours plus tard le 21 mai 1981
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
la vème république un président de
gauche entre à l'elysée
et comme toujours c'est pierre tourlier
qui conduit la voiture
[Musique]
la réception a été grandiose on est
arrivé avec la voiture
les les honneurs les gardes la musique
la fanfare tous les honneurs dus à
président de la république fraîchement
élu nous assistons maintenant depuis le
rond point des champs elysées l'avenue
marigny à l'arrivée du cortège
présidentiel avec françois mitterrand
la voiture pénètre maintenant dans la
cour d'honneur de l'elysée
la voiture de françois mitterrand qui
conduit par son chauffeur garde du corps
pierre tourlier découvre un monde qu'il
ne soupçonnait pas il n'en croit pas ses
yeux
alors moi qui arrivais de ma banlieue je
riais cc dorures c'est hélas il y avait
un grand buffet pire qu au club med
c'était un tas de mangeaille je me
souviens encore c'était marcel de
cerveau le chef cuistot et il y avait
des gros blocs de foie gras comme ça
avec une grosse truffe et je disais à
marcel en rigolant il a va être pourri
temps il y avait un truc noir au milieu
c'était de la truite c'était des
souvenirs comme ça
[Musique]
l'ancien occupant le président valéry
giscard d'estaing vient tout juste de
quitter les lieux au fond du jardin
un détail intrigue la nouvelle équipe
alors ici quand on est arrivé les gens
qu'on dit vous fait pas savoir la fumée
qui s'échappait du point or s'il ya un
incinérateur à signer a peur il doit
être dans le coin et il ya eu des des
volutes de fumée pendant près d'une
semaine ou loti brûler tout l'autre
c'est valéry giscard d'estaing le
président sortant qui quitte le palais
de l'elysée sur un célèbre une sortie
volontairement théâtrale pour un
président humilié par la défaite
jusqu'au bout valéry giscard d'estaing a
cru qu'il serait réélu
tous les dossiers cachés tous les
dossiers plus ou moins magouilles et
tous avaient disparu thaçi en avait pas
d'ailleurs auprès de françois mitterrand
pierre tourlier est l'homme des petits
secrets pendant trente ans il a été son
garde du corps
son chauffeur son complice voilà ça
c'est la porte par laquelle on sortait
presque tous les soirs comme on voulait
pas être trop suivi mais il est beaucoup
plus que cela encore l'homme de
confiance
l'homme de l'ombre en 1985 lorsque
pierre épouse isabelle intendant au
palais de l'elysée le président de la
république et témoin de mariage et c'est
lui pierre tourlier qui trouve le
célèbre surnom de françois mitterrand à
une époque où un jeune socialiste
commence à lui faire de l'ombre
un certain michel rocard je l'appelais
tonton en 1977 quand les assauts de
rocard se sont faits un peu plus
pressant en disant qu'il était archaïque
il était vieux et moi qui vivais tous
les jours avec lui j'ai pensé que
l'archaïque le vieux ce n'est pas
vraiment son nom je l'ait appelé tonton
parce que j'étais cibistes et mon nom ci
visent ces têtes ont donc joui
retransmis
en 1981 quand il s'assied dans le
fauteuil de président de la république
françois mitterrand veut faire table
rase du passé
oubliez les épisodes troubles comme
cette francisque dont pétain l'avait
décoré à vichy en 1942 rappeler des
moments plus glorieux comme son action
dans la résistance il veut changer son
image
le 21 mai 1981 son premier acte de
président est d'aller au panthéon se
recueillir sur les cendres de jean
moulin héros de la résistance
une cérémonie pensée pour marquer
l'histoire réglé à la minute près
la presse est cantonné derrière un
cordon de policiers
tout est prévu tout sauf les paparazzi
comme jean gabriel barthélémy qui vont
jouer les trublions
[Musique]
il y avait la foule qui monte avec lui
il habitait là il y avait une bousculade
énorme
c'est là où j'ai arraché mes semelles de
chaussures dans la bousculade r je me
rate neige me rate mais pourquoi être
sur lui et les gens poussaient tellement
fort que j'ai réussi à me tenir à me
tenir à me tenir et c'est mes
chaussettes s'aimer mais semaine qui
sont décollées donc là ici sont arrêtés
quand on est arrivé là il y avait la
sécurité rapprochée du président qui
était avec nous ils nous ont dit de nous
mettre sur le côté est content il est
parti tout seul je me suis dit merde
c'est une bonne photo parce qu'ici je
n'avais rien fait du tout donc je me
suis jetée derrière lui
j'ai fait une photo peu là les flics me
tombe dessus il nous remet de son côté
d'autres photographes essaye de la faire
lui toutefois y aller mais moi je
recharge en couleurs parce que je
voulais la faire en couleur j'ai raté la
couverture de match parce qu'elle est en
noir et blanc mais j'ai jamais réussi à
leur faire
vous
ça c'est la photo
on a l'impression qu'il est seul c'est
ça qui est drôle c'est que de l'autre
côté il ya une foule immense jusqu'en
bas jusqu'à avoir de la rue s'est
remplie il sait qu'il a hier lui parce
que je suis tout près je suis comme je
suis un tué 1 m 20 derrière lui un
médecin quand à peine les lasers un
moment solennel pour lui va pas bouger
va pas se retourner
c'est filmé en direct seuls les
techniciens de la télévision publique
ont l'autorisation d'entrer dans le
panthéon pour assurer la retransmission
mais un jeune photographe qui deviendra
plus tard le paparazzi le plus célèbre
de france va réaliser l'un de ses
premiers exploits
pascal rostain travaille alors pour
paris match et il est le seul à ne pas
être accrédités et ça les énerve décide
d'essayer de me promener entre les
différents endroits de la cérémonie je
vais pour entrer au panthéon il ya des
flics qui m'arrête à l'entrée qui dit
mais qu'est ce que tu fais gênant je
vais juste faire trois photos et puis je
ressors la chance et la malchance est
une faute professionnelle des pères
lazareff il me laisse passer descend
l'escalier joie une crypte et là je
tombe sur deux caméraman et les mecs
assez sympa il dit mais qui souffre août
à parois êtes là il y en a qui dit film
ont emboîté il le scotch avec du daf
heures sur sa caméra il me dit fais
gaffe ils envoient des flics pour de
virer et il me donne son casque et sa
caméra qui était un truc qui devait
faire 700 kg un truc énorme
et à ce moment là les flics arrivent lui
il a les badges qu'il faut ils viennent
vers moi m'a alors dit plus et vous les
blaireaux ch avec la régie il pense pas
que ça puisse être mois et à ce
moment-là rentrer réalisateur pour
m'expliquer les plans qu'il faut faire
il arrive tu fais pas de zoom tu fais un
panneau je comprenais rien de ce qui me
racontait et du coup l'autre après il
reprend sa caméra il avait entendu ce
que voulait le réalisateur et je
reprends les boîtiers et elles sont là
quelques minutes plus tard mitterrand
rentrer
l époque on avait des boîtiers qui
faisait énormément de bruit et donc je
fais une rafale au moteur et je sais
qu'à au journal à paris match il regarde
évidemment la cérémonie retransmise en
direct et roger thérond dit j'espère que
c'est un photographe de paris match et
non celle photo va nous coûter cher
la photo de pascal rostain fera le tour
du monde
[Musique]
les photographes ont déjoué facilement
les services de sécurité dans
l'entourage du président on commence à
se dire que ceux ci ne sont peut-être
pas à la hauteur
françois mitterrand n'aime pas la police
ils la soupçonnent d'être de droite il
n'a pas confiance dans les hommes des
voyages officiels
encore moins dans les services secrets
il faut changer
pierre tourlier a entendu parler d'un
jeune officier de gendarmerie qui
dirigent depuis 1974 une unité d'élite
le gign
[Musique]
depuis 1974
soixante deux interventions qu'un sport
ce n'est maîtrisé
si lorsqu'ils partiront en mission
l'officier s'appelle christian prouteau
un jour de juillet 1982 on lui demande
de venir au palais de l'elysée pour
rencontrer le tout nouveau président de
la république moi aucun homme dans ma
vie m'a impressionné aucun ni avec un
fusil mais avec un stylo nelly je sais
pas comment vous dire déjà vous n'avez
pas envie lui taper dans le dos et lui
détesté ça la familiarité et j'avais vu
quelqu'un à l'aise je mets et le nombre
de gens qui le tutoyaient se compter sur
les doigts
j'ai vu chirac premier ministre pendant
la cohabitation devant lui pas du tout
il monsieur le président james au
président permettez moi juste de vous
dire que ce soir je ne suis pas le
premier ministre et vous n'êtes pas le
président de la république nous sommes
deux candidats à égalité et qu'ils se
soumettent au jugement des français
seuls qui comptent
vous me permettrez donc que vous avez
monsieur mitterrand et vous avez tout à
fait raison monsieur le premier ministre
la mission que françois mitterrand
confie à christian prouteau est double
d'abord renforcer la lutte
antiterroriste confiait jusque là aux
seuls services secrets en 1983 il crée
la cellule antiterroriste de l'elysée
mission numéro deux protégés françois
mitterrand en 1983
christian prouteau créé le gspr groupe
de sécurité de la présidence de la
république
90 gendarmes et policiers au service du
président jour et nuit
jeux divers jeux mettre à côté 12 24
heures sur 24
il m'a répondu assez lourd ce que vous
nous demandez là mais bien évidemment si
vous assurer la sécurité ce sera tout le
temps il avait une manière à lui de vous
faire comprendre que l'entretien était
une terminale un refrain d'auchel tout
et j'ai tapé les fesses collées sur ma
chaise quelque chose de plus subtil
je voudrais que vous sachiez que j'ai
pas voté pour il y en a eu assez
je me sens mal au rebut lapointe jean et
je repars l'exploit j'avais pas me
prendre les pieds dans le tapis qui a vu
par terre christian prouteau
on vous connaît depuis longtemps sont
pas relus bien entendu les qualités de
courage que j'ai eu déjà l'occasion de
célébrer le courage et d'esprit de
décision même s'il n'a pas voté pour lui
christian prouteau à gagner très vite la
confiance du président qui lui donnera
la légion d'honneur en 1992
françois mitterrand sait qu'il peut
compter sur lui y compris pour les
missions les plus étonnantes comme ce
jour de 1984 ou sur un tarmac d'aéroport
devant l'ensemble du gouvernement en
rang d'oignons il fait arrêter son
falcon qui s'apprêtait à décoller
apparemment il à une requête de la plus
haute importance et on voit dans la
porte
celui qu'on reconnaît tout de suite sur
métal présent la république himself
tout le monde se regarde le premier
ministre en tête
miso l'intérieur venise à la défense que
qu'avait le président je fais comme ça
fm oui oui à la distance je pars bois
belle foule m et je me dis quand même ça
doit être important je monte à la coupe
et le président me regarde dit
en commandant ça va bientôt 19 heures il
va y avoir dallas enregistré le mois je
vais pas arriver à temps et tout d'un
coup tout un pan de vos certitudes ses
crocs l'homme que j'admirais regarder
dallas qui ne paraissait pas plus mais
le dôme qui puisse exister
[Musique]
et je vais pouvoir le dire à personne
parce que personne ne va me croire et
bien voilà je prenne un air l'air de
quelqu'un n'ont pas complètement
désabusé mais l'air de quelqu'un qui a
vraiment sur ses épaules toute la
responsabilité de la république à
travers que la mission peut être enfin
plaisir président
[Musique]
regardez lyon quelques feuilletons suivi
vu aller chercher souvent de la crise
mercredi matin
moi j'ai jamais entendu prononcer un mot
grossier chaque fois qu'ils voyaient jr
il disait salopards je suis beau d'or
que d'une certaine manière toutes les
intrigues qui avait dans dallas y
compris en famille même avec son
meilleur ami tous les coups sont permis
le s'en délecter un peu il aimait bien
cette parodie qu'il n'en n'était
peut-être pas complètement françois
mitterrand était-il un manipulateur
comme jr un remarquable stratège en tout
cas incapable d'obliger quelqu'un à
faire exactement ce qu'il voulait de lui
sans même avoir à dire un mot
diego goldberg le photographe s'en est
aperçu un jour de 1982 où détour d'une
séance photo qui l'a beaucoup marqué ce
passé les temps à françois mitterrand ça
a c'est à lui et la mairie il avait
acheté le reste elle plan d'eau il a
demandé à pierre de l'aider à retrouver
les lieux
bref facile peut-être part de l'autre
côté
donc voilà ce jour là diego est seul
avec le président il veut faire une
photo de lui au milieu des bois aux
marchands synapses comme ça car mon
honneur on arrive à une carrière et je
me suis dit peut-être c'est sûrement là
pour faire une image et je commence à
lui dire est ce que ce que deux on peut
s'arrêter ici et me di meco très courant
et mehdi vous rester là et le prr diégou
ne comprends pas il n'a pas encore fait
la moindre faute ou lorsque soudain
j'entends des bruits d'eau
lequel comme si quelqu'un marcher sur
l'eau et j'essaye de voir d'où ça vient
leçon et je vois tu es une un cas un
ruisseau en bas et à ma surprise qu'est
ce que je vois au fond du ruisseau il
vient ils marchent sur l'eau c'est beau
joe nouveau la rouge sont montées aux
chapeaux et ses unités je crois pas mes
yeux je descends du centre d'optique il
était loin d'être un longue objectif et
je fais le gâteau cette image donnée
surpris en même temps parce que je me
rends compte que c'est une machine
vraiment extraordinaire inhabituel de
voir un président la république les ans
à diego ont ni sur cette image françois
mitterrand la pensée en fait je crois
que c'est lui qui qu'il a construit
cette image mais il savait xp10 il
venait et s'il fait si lui elle est cool
ça moi j'étais là pour faire la photo
c'est dodo début de son mandat
c'est une façon de dire voilà le voilà
ce que je suis l'homme graves sérieux
solitaire je crois qu'il voulait surtout
sen il faisait quelque chose et prévoyez
deux ou trois coups après c'était
quelqu'un de particulièrement brillant à
ce niveau là un calculateur
oui je pense bon quoi qu'il ait jamais
été très bons en calcul mais
machiavélique machiavélique wade il
était toujours très très très ambigu il
était mystérieux il était isolé mais ils
n'étaient pas accessibles si ça c'est
pas quelqu'un c'est monsieur le
président quoi jacques chirac ou nicolas
sarkozy ou même françois hollande j'ai
pas dire qu'on leur tape sur l'épaule
mais il vous tutoient naturellement
enfin on est plus ils nous donnent
l'impression qu'on est plus proche lui
avait toujours une distance cette
distance
guy le querrec a pu l'éprouver en 1982
il photographie françois mitterrand
posant pour un sculpteur daniel druet
dix séances d'une heure afin de réaliser
le buste du président un moment étonnant
c'est un homme avec qui on a assez peu
parlé qui a été très courtois et pour
une dure gentiment vous n'avez pas trop
froid enfin y avait rien de glacial dans
l'attitude
mais il y avait rien non plus il va pas
me demander qu'est ce qui vous a donné
envie de faire de la photo ou moins de
dix ans que si vous êtes donné leur vie
de devenir président de la république il
réside une certaine intimidations
parfois en plus
mitterrand reçoit des gens qui viennent
discuter dont parfois politiques
je me rappelle qu'avec parfois je me
suis dit je me bouche les oreilles parce
que si je m'approchais pour mais j'étais
pas là pour entendre ce qui se disait
peut-être même des données peut-être pas
secrète mais en tout cas un team de la
politique à la 8ème séance de pose
le sculpteur mécontent de son travail
détruit entièrement le buste pour
repartir de zéro
daniel druet le sculpteur ne s'en sort
pas pour lui mitterrand était quelqu'un
qui n'arrivait pas à saisir
lui considère que c'est un homme qui se
livre pas finalement à la 10ème séance
pour le sculpteur
le buste est achevée il vient se
rapprocher du buste et toucher un pelage
ou à vous prenez pas en quoi que je les
joue sexy creuse ou peut-être il va
faire un petit truc mais sans jamais
reproché au sculpteur away pas fait
bouger papa il accordait une grande
liberté
artiste alors dorures elle dit tu es
d'âge ressenti qu'il avait sculpté comme
il serait dans dix ans
le président a l'air satisfait du
travail quant aux photos de guy le
querrec c'est autre chose
c'était un peu ambigu c'est à dire que
je suis accepter venant des photos et
vers la fin je dis monsieur le président
j'aimerais publiés il m'a simplement dit
ah oui tu tiens pas chercher quelqu'un
qui n'aime pas du tout s'exhiber jeu
peut paraître bizarre même public comme
vous je ne fais pas ce genre de
concession en fait françois mitterrand
veut bien parfois s'exhiber mais entend
tout maîtriser
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit de son image
pascal rostain s'en est aperçu lui aussi
au cours d'une séance photo à l'hiver
paris match nous envoie photographier le
noël du président les deux super frelon
présidentielle se pose dans le champ et
donc il me demande ce qu'on veut faire
je suis pas quelque chose de simple les
petits enfants sur les genoux la crèche
au sapin de noël et me dit non mettez
vous en bas du jardin et nous sortirons
après le déjeuner donc on a fait des
photos façon paparazzi avec un gros
téléobjectif tout ça est organisée on
était sur pied
on jouait avec les chiens de tonton
c'est plutôt sympa donc en fait il a
essayé de nous instrumentaliser le
président s'occupe de tout fausse
planque pour les paparazzis ou encore
reportage télé marc ont fait part effet
à la che dans les landes résidence
secondaire dès mi terrain il met en
scène sa vie privée
il veut donner l'image d'un homme de la
terre avec ses deux ânes ses chiens les
séquences tournées à plusieurs années
d'intervalle sont presque toujours les
mêmes au mot près sha tin oo à cette
altitude
souvent elles font avec ma soeur on le
regarde c'est pas possible qu'un homme
gayton responsabilité s'amuse avec une
année à ce point l'autre image qu'il
tient à donner et celle du couple qu'il
forme avec son épouse danielle unis est
complice du moins en apparence
françois mitterrand a été le premier
président français a vraiment utilisé et
comprendre le pouvoir de l'image c'est
vrai que c'était pas très compliqué il
suffisait de prendre le modèle américain
quand on voit comment john fitzgerald
kennedy offrait à l'amérique
toutes les semaines des photos de son
intimité je me souvient évidemment de la
photo john jones ou bureau mais toutes
les semaines tu avais caroline à la mer
carabine à la montagne caroline à cheval
enfin c'était vraiment l'utilisation de
l'image pour raconter une belle histoire
et pour en plus parce que là les deux
personnages se ressemblent
kennedy mitterrand pour quoi il
ressemble parce qu'ils ont tous les deux
cela dit comme beaucoup de présidents
des histoires extra conjugales donc
c'est peut-être aussi pour permettre de
donner de nous donner aux médias et aux
peuples ac 2-2 matière de vie
personnelle pour nous éviter d'aller
chercher s'il ya autre chose cachée dans
le placard car françois mitterrand est
un grand séducteur
allez pierre tourlier a vu et entendu
beaucoup de choses
s'il y a un lieu propice aux secrets
c'est bien la voiture du président
c'était le lieu
françois mitterrand parlait le plus s'il
était sûr pas été écoutés ils étaient
sûrs d'eux que ce ne soit pas répéter
donc ça faisait partie de son sa bulle
[Musique]
et les choses que vous avez jamais
raconté ouais et que je raconterai
jamais forcément les longs des favoris
qu'ils étaient
pierre tourlier restera discret mais
quelques noms ont été publiés dans la
presse comme celui de la chanteuse
dalida la speakerine catherine langeais
un amour de jeunesse
ou encore cette jolie blonde
photographié ici pendant un repas à la
tchèque kristyna force journaliste
suédoise
il n'allait pas chez elle il faut de
temps en temps l'un disait oui je pense
que salle flattait d'avoir cette blonde
accompagnées de forts à l'euro si
mitterrand a eu beaucoup de femmes dans
sa vie
seuls trois ont véritablement compter
daniel l'officiel anne pingeot la femme
cachée et mazarine sa fille dont la
france n'apprend l'existence qu'en 1994
alors qu'elle a déjà 20 ans
françois mitterrand et danielle gouze
rénal se marie en 1944 ils ne se
quitteront jamais ils auront deux
garçons gilbert et jean christophe
[Musique]
on est arrivés rue de bièvre en 1973 il
achète une grande maison dans le
quartier latin à paris
voilà il y à bien longtemps qu aucune
caméra n'est entré dans ces lieux 22 rue
de bièvre à paris domicile privé des
mitterrand là c'est la cuisine la salle
à manger
c'est l'heure du petit déjeuner que le
président prend ce matin en compagnie de
ses deux fils la chambre de daniel la
chambre du président le bureau du
président un grand bureau avec de leurs
plus loin c'était le secrétariat au c
c'est une co propriétaire la
copropriétaire la voici
elle s'appelle catherine jouanneau elle
a racheté le bureau du président au
dernier étage du 22 rue de bièvre et y
installer ses appartements
elle accepte de nous faire la visite
c'est un privilège jusque là catherine
jouanneau a toujours refusé de montrer
ces lieux au journaliste catherine était
la fille d'un couple d'amis de françois
mitterrand décédé dans un accident de la
route il avait acheté un deux pièces au
22 rue de bièvre
catherine a toujours vécu ici elle a
gardé les lieux presque intacte comme un
musée j'appelle toujours période
françois alors le rhinocéros est resté
et surtout les bibliothèques
parce que daniel m'a demandé de ne pas
toucher la vidéothèque s'est passé
livres and lift certaine nous mais la
bibliothèque près celle qu'il a fait
voilà et là vous allez retrouver affiche
qui vous dit quelque chose
[Musique]
catherine a vécu 20 ans aux côtés de
françois et danielle mitterrand la vie
ici était mouvementée
la maison est gay c'est ici la noë gay
la maison est triste si là nous est
triste que ce soit françois ou les
autres nous habitons dans la même maison
continuons de vivre ensemble avec
plaisir
dès les premiers temps du mariage
pourtant daniel se rend compte que son
mari exige une liberté absolue
il est très souvent absent c'est un don
juan
catherine jouanneau est le témoin
privilégié de la vie de ce drôle de
couple je dis toujours que bon c'est
tous les histoires qu'il ya eu mais que
daniel et françois c'est un vrai couple
moi je les ai vus parlé le matin quand
daniel était pas là il n'a fait tous les
jours en vélo au téléphone vous l'avez
sûrement dit et surtout je les ai vus à
2 enfin on est étroit et c'est un vrai
couple stoy la veille avait autre chose
mais je veux dire c'était c'était un
vrai couple autre chose
c'est l'autre vie de françois mitterrand
celle qu'il vivait clandestinement avec
son deuxième amour
anne pingeot ils se rencontrent pour la
première fois à hossegor en vacances
anne est la fille d'un ami de françois
mitterrand elle n'a que 14 ans six ans
plus tard elle monte à paris et devient
sa maîtresse
ils ont 27 ans d'écart en 1974 une
enfant naît de cette union
mazarine
ceux qui sont dans le secret se comptent
sur les doigts d'une main
et parmi eux bien sûr il y a pire tous
liés il y avait daniel qui était son
écoute sans son ami c'est et puis il y
avait à l'âne c'était la culture c'était
le jeunesse aussi il avait même des
périodes où souvient encore est la même
des périodes de jalouse quand elle
partait par exemple à l'étranger alors
il s'appelait bien entendu très souvent
et d'arrêter pas plus demandés et était
avec qui tu étais où avec mais laisse
moi j'étais avec le terek après
l'élection de 1981 françois mitterrand
installe anne et mazarine dans un
immeuble de la république quai branly et
il organise sa vie entre ces deux
familles alors le soir après le travail
quitter le bureau de l'elysée et est
venu se reposer au quai branly
c'était son sa maison c'est là où
habitait and c'est là où habitait raza
rinne fait c'était sa demeure principale
jack le dimanche soir où pâturent
venette deux week-ends je l'emmenais
directement à eux de bièvre
[Musique]
cette vie compliquée c'est christian
prouteau qui va être chargé de
l'organiser dès qu'il rencontre françois
mitterrand à l'elysée
il comprend que ça va être un véritable
casse tête
il m'a dit d'abord que sa femme l'a pas
besoin de protection indien lâché
policiers ça suffira ça me laisse
perplexe 10 pour le reste allez voir où
cela andré rousselet le directeur de
cabinet de françois mitterrand et
rousselet d'euros par le bras il sort du
bureau il dit c'est délicat les voir de
gros sous il à vous expliquer
françois de grossouvre l'un des
conseillers de françois mitterrand
l'homme des dossiers sensibles de grosse
ombre à gages agacé démenti qu est ce
qui a encore de beaux jours me dis
carrément de led zep comme moi j'étais
au courant de rien je ne savais pas tout
de suite je vais poser la question jdo
donc je suppose que c'est ça va être
secret secret laissez votre travail fait
en sorte que ça ne se sache pas beaucoup
de gens vous diront qu'ils étaient au
courant c'est pas mal je peux vous
affirmer ce n'était pas comme j'en ai
plus par an et ce qu'ils étaient au
courant ne savais pas qu'il était au
courant dont personne n'en parlait la
deuxième femme du président n'a aucune
existence officielle comme le prouve
cette séquence tournée en 1986 françois
mitterrand inaugure le tout nouveau
musée d'orsay
le président de la république entouré de
jacques chirac de valéry giscard
d'estaing découvre l'un des plus beaux
musées du monde anne pingeot et
conservatrice au musée c'est elle qui
fait la visite
mais ce jour-là elle n'apparaît pas sur
les images de la télévision
sur les photos pourtant on ne voit
qu'elle drapé de rouge est le regard de
françois mitterrand ce jour là se passe
de commentaires la vie avec cette
famille cachée aura été parfois
difficile les moments d'intimité c'était
souvent avec âme et mazarine ton monte
devant âme était derrière et mazarine
était derrière moi et souvent joaillier
la main de françois mitterrand qui qui
passait derrière timidement et est
accroché la main dan pour lui
transmettre sans sont l'amour qu'ils
avaient
c'est la rue saint benoît où ou aller à
l'école un marine ici là alala fait la
maternelle et la commune harry film lui
venait alors quand il y avait des
périodes électorales devant l'école il y
avait des des panneaux de d'élections et
ils s'arrêtaient il faisait semblant de
dire les les professions de foi tout ce
qu'ils faisaient c'était regarder
mazarine rentrée dans l'école
sa fille s'était c'était sa fille
mazarine étaient du lot avec son père
bel été capable de lui dire des non tu
que tu t'occupes pas de moi tu
t'intéresses que à ton poste ou des
choses comme ça des choses que font les
enfants quand ils ont la pression
qu'elle n'occupe pas la place qui
devrait même si elle a compris très tôt
que malheureusement elle ne pourrait que
derrière le teint du miroir dans paris
cela commence à se murmurer le président
aurait une fille cachée l'hebdomadaire
d'extrême droite minute veut publier une
photo de mazarine et anne à la sortie de
l'école à la tête de la cellule
antiterroriste christian prouteau est
chargée de dissuader les journalistes
[Musique]
mais celui qui inquiète le plus
l'entourage de françois mitterrand est
incertain jean-edern hallier un écrivain
un original qui s'est mis en tête de
révéler au grand public le secret du
président sur instruction de mitterrand
toutes les lignes téléphoniques de
jean-edern hallier sont mises sur écoute
par la cellule antiterroriste trop
mignon mais en même temps quelqu'un qui
avait besoin que l'on parle de lui il
avait dit qu'il enlèverait la fille de
mitterrand elle était petite mazarine à
laver huit ans donc ce que nous essayons
de savoir c'est ce qui m'ennuie lancer
parce que il aurait fait un sitting
devant l'école de mazarine sais pas si
vous imaginez
il en était capable je ne voyais pas
devoir gérer quelque chose sans avoir un
petit temps d'avancé sur lui et pourra
pas en avant si vous éliminez des coudes
en place ouais comme il avait pu le rô
le téléphone était coupé c'est embêtant
qu'est ce que c'est bon on arrête avec
ce téléphone d'écouter les cabines
téléphoniques c'est compliqué téléphone
pareil à un moment il avait plu l'olp
l'électricité mitterrand l'a fait
rétablir parce que je suis allé voir est
en écoute et la plus expressive chatte
rétablir l'électricité
ce conte elle mérite pas ça cette mue
côté bizarre de mitterrand
les écoutes de la cellule antiterroriste
ne vise pas seulement jean-edern hallier
son entourage des centaines de lignes
téléphoniques d'avocats d'artistes de
journalistes sont surveillés surtout ces
écoutes sont illégales le scandale
éclate dans la presse en 1993 une
enquête est ouverte
christian prouteau sera condamné à huit
mois de prison avec sursis
[Applaudissements]
il m'a dit je suis désolée nous avons
ce que vous avez à dire le secret de
françois mitterrand sera finalement
révélé au grand public en novembre 1994
sébastien vallier là et paparazzi il
travaille pour pascal rostain et c'est
par hasard qu'il va avoir un tuyau
décisif quelqu'un doit dire la classe de
mazarine la fille de mitterrand on s'est
dit mais non il avec des fils base là on
s'y intéresse
on en parle un peu autour de nous les
gens nous disent oui il y en a qui me
dit c'est une rumeur d'autres c'est pas
vrai ou de façon c'est pas possible à
faire on le sait mais on a essayé mais
c'est trop compliqué et caetera et nous
on est jeune et naïf on se dit bon à
rien donc on à l'école on l'a repéré
physiquement on la suit en est on arrivé
au domicile où elle vit avec sa maman
anne pingeot et là on commence sa
planque qui durant un certain temps je
me rappelle plus peut-être deux semaines
trois semaines et un beau jour voie de
la sécurité qui commencent à arriver des
policiers en civil alors on envoie 1 2 3
4 5
on voit que toute la rue comment secte
surveiller on se dit bon là il se passe
quelque chose
sébastien vallier la comprends que ce
jour là
mazarine a rendez vous avec son père il
décide de les suivre
ça a été assez simple pour nous à la
filature c'est que il y avait quand même
pas mal il ya deux voitures policiers
mais il ya un camion qui s'est mis entre
nous un camion de travaux
mais les vitres étaient pas teinter donc
à travers les vitres arrières et le
pare-brise de trucs on était nous
complètement cachée mais on voyait très
bien les deux voitures
donc si ça tournait à droite ou à gauche
on aurait pu mais là il s'est trouvé que
ça a été tout droit jusque là bas
là bas c'est un restaurant de poisson
réputé où françois mitterrand a
l'habitude d'aller le divellec on y
allait souvent parce que ton tant adoré
le poisson le patron jacques était très
sympa
habituellement lorsque françois
mitterrand anne et mazarine se
retrouvent ici ils prennent leurs
précautions
voilà alors c'est par là que des fois à
mes mazarine passé quand on soit
mitterrand était déjà installé le
président est arrivé
sébastien vallier là et son collègue
n'ont plus qu'à attendre sans se faire
repérer des jeunes et pour nous il a
duré une semaine
tellement c'était long à cause d'eux
voilà parce qu'on avait notre angle on
voit bien dit c'est vous remarquez qu'à
beaucoup de passages de voitures et il
ya notamment il ya un feu là dès qu'il
est rouge et il durera plus d'une minute
dès que vous avez un bus qui est au feu
on voit plus rien mais une minute c'est
très long parce que le moment on a fait
les photos il a dû durer vingt secondes
donc on aurait très bien pu ne rien voir
au moment où ils sortent on est
exactement la bonne façon l'appareil
étaient cachés derrière on se baisse
comme ça en ce moment position et à ce
moment là il prend la main de mazarine
il embrasse mazari
on fait la sortie et on se planque
derrière on pouvait pas les voir dans la
mesure où ils étaient cachés derrière
les balustrades à la gare des invalides
et s'est passé loin ça fait quand même
pas loin de 100 m et après ils sont tous
montés dans des voitures tout le monde
est parti et nous on est restés en était
là vous avez bon c'est bon on est sauvés
là on à l'appareil les photos c'est pas
fait arrêter ben alors on s'est dit bon
on a les photos maintenant ça va être
une note triste parce que qui va oser
sortir ça le directeur de paris match
contacter roland dumas ministre et
avocat de françois mitterrand il va
jouer les intermédiaires à l'époque
mitterrand avait le pouvoir de dire non
mettre la pression et paris match lui à
lui a posé la question on va demander la
permission entre guillemets et
mitterrand a dit c'est quand même une
belle histoire
note il dit mais monsieur le président
ces feux rouges ou feu vert et lui tend
les photos en lui disant la presse sait
ce qu'elle doit faire
je suis sorti à peu près trois semaines
à un mois après où là bas on a senti
françois mitterrand soulagé il a dû se
dire que de toute façon à un moment ou
un autre il fallait que l'histoire sorte
je pense pas qu'ils comptaient mourir
sans que ça soit sorti mais c'est vrai
qu'il se dit c'est une manière indirecte
sens que je déclenche moi même la
reconnaissance officielle sur le perron
de l'elysée je vous présente la chine
je m'affiche surreprésentés moi je vais
rencontrer quelques temps après il m'a
sorti une petite phrase genre oui elle
était belle les photos elle est belle ma
fille et je dis oui c'est vrai mais si
le président est très belle
[Musique]
oui
e
la révélation de la famille cachée de
françois mitterrand précède de quelques
mois la fin du second septennat depuis
plus de dix ans un mal ronge le
président un cancer de la prostate
il a parfois du mal à tenir debout diego
goldberg demandent à pouvoir suivre
françois mitterrand pour sa dernière
semaine au pouvoir je crois que le
moment le plus émouvant pour moi ça a
été le premier show que je suis arrivé
me voit pour la première fois depuis des
années ne voit il me dit merci
j'imagine disant merci d'être venu merci
des bla et puis mehdi et yapi tenais mon
visage chose qui me répondrez quoi il ne
s'est lui vu très affaibli très fatigué
tout temps prenez du temps pour vous
êtes seul espoir est posée
françois mitterrand quitte l'elysée en
mai 1995 et va s'installer dans un
appartement près du champs de mars rue
frédéric le play avec anne pingeot et
mazari mme
c'est là que sébastien va lier la fera
l'une de ses dernières photos c'était
une photo assez rare parce qu'il y en a
pas eu beaucoup c'était une photo de
mitterrand anne pingeot ensemble se
promenant bras dessus bras dessous donc
ce jour là pour moi ça a été un peu une
apparition et j'avais pas vraiment
d'endroit pour me cacher je suis rentré
dans un bus de japonais qui étaient là
qui déposaient des la porte s'est ouvert
je suis rentré me rappelle et j'ai sorti
le thé objectif j'ai fait des photos et
tous les japonais me prenez vous en
photo si je demandais ce que je faisais
pas ce qu'ils voyaient que j'avais quand
même un tel objectif alors j'essaye de
leur explique c'était l'ancien président
s'était compliqué c'était c'était un peu
à un moment un peu magique parce que
vraiment je désespérais de les voir un
jour ensemble tous les deux c'est au
bord du nil en egypte que françois
mitterrand parce son dernier réveillon
le 1er janvier 1995 aux côtés de
mazarine et de sa mère
encore une fois la photo est signée
pascal rostain c'est la dernière photo
du président mitterrand
la dernière photo de son vivant parce
que c'est son voyage a souvent on sait
qu'il est malade tout le monde sait
qu'il est malade on a révélé dans paris
match sa maladie en 1981 lorsque
mitterrand rentrer d'égypte quelques
jours plus tard il est très affaibli
pierre tourlier vient de chercher et
l'emmène rue frédéric le play on arrivé
ici il était deux heures du matin et
d'un seul coup c'était juste devant la
porte se retourne abaisse les les
boutons de sécurité et me dit pierre on
y va je le regarde tu mets toute la
soirée vous m'avez dit que vous étiez
fatigué que depuis tout à l'heure vous
dit vous avez fatigué vous avez dit non
en pierres on y va et là je dis non
monsieur le président ce propos le
docteur tarot on n'y va pas il se tourne
vers moi et me dit il ya six mois vous
n'auriez pas dit ça voyez pas refuser
il descend et puis je reste accroché à
mon volant
c'est la dernière fois que j'ai conduit
jours après elle était mort pendant
plusieurs jours les proches les
politiques des fils rue frédéric le play
pour rendre hommage à l'ancien président
l'avis de françois mitterrand se finira
sur une énigme
cette photo sur son lit de mort prises à
l'insu de la famille savez je sais que
je devrais pas dire ça mais la photo est
belle
françois mitterrand sur son lit de mort
c'est en plus il a ce visage ce visage
enfin où ils souffrent le plus où il a
cette sérénité
le seul problème c'est que cette photo
elle a été volée elle a été marchander
et je trouve ça lamentable
[Musique]
d'abord j'ai passé et ce que si j'aurai
une location est ce que je leur ai fait
[Musique]
oui
la réponse est que je ne l'aurais pas
volé mais que j'aurais demandé et je
pense que peut-être si j'aurais demandé
à daniel et m'aurait dit oui la photo a
fait une double page dans paris match
on sait qu'elle aurait été payée 500
mille francs de l'époque un peu plus de
80000 euros
mais vingt ans plus tard on n'a aucune
certitude sur le nom de son auteur
esther de plus sanaa deux mystères de
france au leader françois mitterrand a
laissé en héritage une génération
politique et une certaine façon
d'exercer le pouvoir
[Musique]
dites vous bien que vous n'auriez rien
compris si vous saviez que je suis tout
à fait libre à l'égard de qui que ce
soit et qui n'est pas de force au monde
par le force au monde à l'égard des cas
je le sois tout à fait libre